that is bindi Irwin out for a stroll
yesterday with a man
Chandler fouled the Dancing with the
Stars finale begins tonight and I don't
know cam but it sounds as if Benny maybe
should've been staying off her feet
listen everybody is hurting at this
stage of the game but my girl bindi woof
feet look like they've been through a
war and then there's this so it's flan
and all the smoke alarms are going off
by loving it so the reason why I'm gonna
be tired at rehearsals today because who
I am and all about smoke alarms going
off her mom and brother also got the
rude awakening it may have derailed
Sunday's rehearsal but that's nothing
compared to finish force problem this is
like The Walking Dead
it's it looks like a flesh-eating
disease or coming off and like holes in
her feet literally holes and she's just
like it's okay we have five more days
left let's just do this oh it's it's
fine
it's beds yet oh it's fine her soul got
admire bindis will to win how about a
foot massage no no it hurts so much you
actually gonna know by the way you
couldn't massage them because there's
literally no skin it's like they're just
like oh like no that kind of old one off
the bad it's bad there are just four
couples remaining and biggie stands
alone I know I can't believe it on the
last go yeah go go all the way and if
the last girl standing wins her partner
Derek it'll be his sixth time that's a
record now of course Derek's sister
julienne will have a say whether or not
he was being a judge but yeah she's also
gearing up for grease live on January
31st on Fox and there it is your first
look at Julianne and Sandy arrington vet
is playing Danny Z